hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen now I know you don't
wanna have to think about this for at
least another week but girls can smell a
shoddy last-minute date night and trust
me it is not a good way to get any girl
in the mood thankfully I've got you
covered with these do's and don'ts for
the ultimate seal the deal Valentine's
Day meal do choose ingredients that feel
festive and on the red and pink foods
are obvious choices for Valentine's Day
and thankfully there are a lot of tasty
options there to choose from California
strawberries are my go-to for everything
from salads to deserves to even main
courses because they're available all
year long they're naturally sweet
they're red and they look like cute
little hearts trust me
girls will appreciate the attention to
detail on the color palette it says hey
girl yeah I'll totally look at linen
swatches with you for a hypothetical
future wedding don't serve foods that
are gonna leave you tired and lethargic
you want the energy to enjoy the night
through dessert and afterwards as well
for those of you in adult love and
consensual relationships of course so
skip the heavy fatty fare like those
cheesy casseroles creamy pasta and the
fattier cuts of meat that are just gonna
lead to a blackout food coma also pace
yourself on the booze while one drink
may lead to a little bit of a buzz I am
ready for bed after two and I'm talking
about in my pajamas with my retainer my
teddy bear and my reading glasses kind
of bad
just to clarify expectations do choose a
menu with ingredients that are actually
good for your health now I may be making
overly favorable assumptions about your
character but do you care about this
girl you want her to be healthy and
strong so that you two can grow old
together right so choose ingredients
with a variety of vitamins minerals and
antioxidants that promote good health
those California strawberries are again
a great choice because they're super low
in calories but they pack more of the
antioxidant vitamin C than your standard
orange plus research suggests that
eating just ate strawberries a day can
help improve heart health manage
diabetes reduce your risk of some
cancers and support brain health and I
know how important your ladies brain is
to you don't choose foods that cause
bloating gas or discomfort aka the kiss
of death or post dessert cuddles I'm
talking no beans
no carbonated drinks no salty sauces no
broccoli and definitely no kale
I know Kayla super trendy and for a
farty brunch with the girls it is a-okay
but for date night just say no do keep
hydrated Hospitality rule number one
never let your guests feel parched and
this is particularly true for your
Valentine's Day date so make sure
there's loss flat or tap water plus some
water rich food this cucumber salad is
the perfect bloat free refreshing
low-calorie starter to kick things off
just start with some shaved cucumber
top it off some diced California
strawberries some toasted almonds and a
little reduced balsamic drizzle I made
by reducing down some balsamic vinegar
to a thick luscious syrup do make it
interactive DIY dishes aren't perfect
for date night because they're flirty
they're shareable and they encourage you
to eat with your hands which is kind of
hot my favorite healthy dessert for date
night is a dark chocolate dipped
strawberry because it's loaded with a
double-headed antioxidant power and
there's no need to add any extra sugar
just melt a hundred grams of 74 80
percent dark chocolate over a bain-marie
and have fun dipping and dunking each
other strawberries in your favorite
toppings I'm using crushed almonds
toasted coconut freeze dried
strawberries and some peppermint candies
to make sure your breath is fresh before
that first kiss of the night see you've
got this just make sure to remember all
the Valentine's Day buzzkill don'ts and
the seal the deal dues to ensure a
pleasure packed meal this Valentine's
Day
thanks so much for watching more great
date night ideas be sure to subscribe to
my channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen
you